I have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine to david p here's
a voicemail that came in hey david this
is tristan orlando florida i watch i do
not have a subscription i watch from
youtube but one day I'm noticed about
you is that you can never pick a side
never it seems like never at least
ninety nine percent of the time you
don't pick the side you're always
neutral and I just wonder why so my
question is why can't you pick a side
why can't you express your personal
opinion why's it always got to be like a
CNN or something wrong yeah I did this
or they did that but you know who knows
her anyways I expect their back for you
listen this is an opinion show up we get
10,000 critiques a month I mean we get
3,000 youtube comment today hundreds of
emails tweets Facebook posts most of the
time were being criticized because we
are giving an opinion this is an opinion
show the entire show is based on my
opinion every story today I have given
you my opinion I don't know Jason how
someone could watch the show and come
away with the critique that I'm I'm
shielding my opinion in some way it's an
opinion show that's all this is no
comment yeah there you go Jason not not
giving his opinion on that very very
strange voicemail on today's bonus show
President Obama has created the largest
protected space on the planet in Hawaii
we will talk about the Islamic state
banning the burqa in northern Iraq after
a veiled woman killed two jihadists and
we will talk about the price of
marijuana in Colorado hint it is not
going up sign up for the bonus show at
david pakman.com slash membership